That's right! Today we're learning with the theme song from Friends.
Coming up!
All right, before we get into today's lesson,
I just wanted to say Thank You so much!
We just hit 400,000 subscribers, and we
so appreciate all of your support so we can continue
bringing you fun lessons like this one every week.
And if you haven't subscribed yet,
what are you waiting for?
We help you to understand natives
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles!
As thanks for all of your support, and
for this huge achievement, we wanted to
give you a special present.
So, if you enjoy these lessons but you want to take your English fluency and comprehension to the next level
It's perfect for you.
It's 33% off of our Premium Fluency Course
Fluent with Friends.
The 55 exclusive lessons that you get with the Fluent with Friends course are very similar
to what you find on this channel.
But, we organize and deliver the best
scenes, episode by episode, for the first two seasons,
together with 20+ page PDF guides,
innovative vocabulary memorization software,
and access to our exclusive Fluency Circle community,
and so much more!
To learn more simply click up here, or down in the description below
and remember to use your exclusive
present - the 33% Off with the coupon code 400k.
Now, without further ado, let's get into today's lesson!
All right! So, the expression you just learned and the name of the song, "I'll be there for you",
is a way to show support to someone, right?
So, I wanted to give you five other expressions,
very colloquial American expressions that you can use to show support or encouragement to a friend.
So, the first one is "hang in there".
What that means basically is that
you're telling your friend that although things are difficult right now, don't give up because things will get better.
Hang in there.
The next one is very similar which is "Stay strong".
So, this is exactly what it sounds like -
you can tell a friend this if they are feeling like
things are difficult, that they need to stay strong,
not get weak, not give up.
And the next one is just a little bit different,
"I'm behind you 100%".
If you're behind someone, that means that
you supports their decision or
you're basically there to lend them a hand.
And if you say that you're behind them 100%,
that basically means that you are fully
behind them. So, it's a way to show them
that with a decision that they're making,
and moving forward, that you will give
them 100% of your support.
So, the next one is really great for giving your friend some encouragement
and that is "The sky's the limit".
It's basically saying that there are no limits, there are no borders.
That they have unlimited potential, nothing is impossible. So, if you're wanting to kind of inspire
someone, this would be a great one to use.
And then finally,
the fifth one is "Every cloud has its silver lining".
This one basically you can use that if your friend
is feeling depressed, if something bad happened to them, you would say
"every cloud has a silver lining"
meaning that even though bad things
happen to us, there's usually always some
positive side to it.
So, even though things seem bad right now
you never know in the future what this is going to lead to.
And, so often in our lives, things that seem negative in the moment
will lead to the most growth, the most learning so we should really never give up in the face of aversion.
And of course the best way to remember any new vocabulary or expressions that you learn
is to put them to use right away.
So, I want you to try this out by picking one
of these expressions you just learned
and writing an example down in the comments below,
and I will correct many of your answers!
If you're enjoying this video, be sure to give it a like because that tells YouTube that you want to be
alerted when we make new videos like this one.
Alright, remember to take advantage of
your Fluency Coupon 400k to get 33% Off
until March 18th on any of our Fluent with Friends packages.
You can find out more with the link down in the description.
All right, I hope that you really enjoyed this lesson!
Music is a fantastic resource to learn
the lyrics, and sing along, which helps
you both to build your vocabulary and
your pronunciation, among other things.
Be sure to subscribe so you don't miss a single lesson.
Also, check out your 33% discount
by using your coupon code 400k on this page.
If you want to learn more music with songs,
check out this playlist, or this other video I think you'll enjoy.
Now it's time to go beyond the classroom,
and LIVE your English!
Aw yeah!